after round the clock debate on saturday
and sunday the u.s senate passed the
last major economic bill of joe biden's
agenda the inflation reduction act on
this vote
the yeas are 50 the nays are 50. the
senate being equally divided the vice
president votes in the affirmative and
the bill as amended is passed
the bill will raise 430 billion dollars
for a wide range of priorities
improving health care coverage tackling
climate change by investing in electric
cars and renewable energy
imposing a mandatory 15 percent income
tax on corporations and cutting the
deficit this bill
will kick-start the era of affordable
clean energy in america it's a game
changer it's a turning point and it's
been a long time in coming
the bill had been considered dead until
democratic leaders negotiated a
compromise with senators joe manchin and
kirsten cinema that guaranteed their
support
senate republicans offered amendment
after amendment in hopes of destroying
the democrats unity
they blocked a plan to require private
health insurers to charge no more than
35 dollars a month for insulin but that
wasn't enough to derail the overall bill
after the vote senate republicans issued
a statement calling the bill a disaster
earlier on sunday and just out of covet
isolation president joe biden signaled
to reporters he thought the bill would
pass
now it's up to the house of
representatives to approve the bill
before biden can sign it into law
that vote is tentatively set for friday
rosalind jordan al jazeera washington